[Music]
this is unexpected
well you never got to go into honeymoon
so we made you dinner
it's a luau we got pineapples and
coconuts hey hey yeah I love you get it
up huh hey Madame and Monsieur the gummy
bears for my idea hmm looks too good to
leave and eat am i right yeah but I made
it for you
oh god soup I love the combination long
gummy bears meat shortly after you and
your brother were born your father and I
divorced and we each took one son
obviously ha ha I got second pick I have
a twin brother my brother
[Music]
finally meeting you your discomfort is
al-arian so how are things career-wise
haha great
you let the most wanted village just get
away you're fired
Jojo great crushing it I brought you
here to continue the family business the
only is in your blood and the growth can
pubs I left that life behind me I
understand hmm I wonder what this does
[Music]
holy-moly become a villain Mogambo
what did you guys do today there's
always a blinder nothing
Oh what about that fool why Oh girls I'm
making learn to appreciate me
differentiate we've been waiting a long
time I saw what once was it it was so
fluffy I thought it was from a day
[Music]
so you two are villains name ah
I mean hello speedy Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Norfolk
[Music]